[Musik]
guten tag mein name ist professor genius
sprechen wir über die artikel der die
das
heute sprechen wir über die
titel der die das
maskulinen nati
eher nehmen wir natürlich für männer
maskulinen artikel der nehmen wir
natürlich für männer
zum beispiel der professor
auch der mann der sohn der koch und noch
viele mehr
alle wochentage monate und jahreszeiten
sind maskulin
also der montag der februar der frühling
der montag der februar der frühling
auch die himmelsrichtungen brauchen den
artikel der
der norden der osten der süden der
westen
der osten der süden der westen
die meisten tageszeiten sind maskulin
die meisten tageszeiten sind noch school
ihn
wir sagen der morgen der vormittag der
mittag der nachmittag der abend aber die
nacht
[Musik]
wir sagen der morgen der vormittag der
mittag der nachmittag der abend aber die
nacht
welchen wir jetzt über meine lieblings
regel
sprechen wir jetzt über meine lieblings
rege
kohl ist maskulin
kohl ist maskulin der wein virgin der
schnaps der sekt der whisky berg
cocktail
das bier
der wein der gin der schnaps der sekt
der whisky der cocktail
aber das bier
jetzt brauche ich eine
kopfschmerztablette
auch das wetter ist oft maskulin aber
nicht immer
auch das wetter ist auf maskulin aber
sie sagen der regen der wind der sturm
der schnee der regenbogen
aber die sonne die wolken
das gewitter das eis
wir sagen der regen der wind der sturm
der schnee der regenbogen
aber die sonne die wolken
das gewitter das eis
normalerweise gilt automarken sind
maskulin
normalerweise gilt automaten sind
maskulin der ferrari der mini der
porsche der vw der 100
der ferrari der mini der branche
der vw der 100
motorradmarken hingegen pochen den
artikeln die
die honda die harley die vespa
willig sind auch frauen feminin
die frau die schwester die ärztin
natürlich sind auch frauen feminin die
frau die schwester die ärztin
zahlen sind familien
zahlen sind feminin
die 1 die 12 die millionen die milliarde
1 die 12 die millionen die milliarde
neutral sind farb nahmen sie brauchen
den artikel das
neutral sind
sie brauchen den artikel das
sagen dass roth das grün das blau das
orange
wir sagen dass roth das grün das blaue
das orange
metalle sind normalerweise ebenfalls
neutral
neutral es heißt nicht nur das metall
sondern auch das gold das silber das
eisen das aluminium
heißt nicht nur das metall sondern auch
das gold das silber das eisen das
aluminium
haben nominal ihren brauchen wir auch
den artikel das
denn wir werben nun analysieren brauchen
wir auch den artikel das
das sind aktionen wie das schwimmen das
lernen das lesen das wandern
professor genius professor genius
stop stop
ihre erklärungen sind zwar sehr
interessant aber sie möchten doch nicht
dass ihre studenten einschlafen
ihre erklärungen sind zwar sehr
interessant aber sie möchten doch nicht
dass ihre studenten einschlafen
jetzt machen wir ein quiz richtig
jetzt machen wir ein quiz
mein name ist dani fohrler und das ist
meine bezaubernde kollegin rebecca
tanner
willkommen bei unserer show der die oder
das
artikel lärm macht spaß unser erstes
wort lautet sommer ist es der die oder
das sommer
raten sie mit
und die richtige antwort lautet
[Musik]
der sommer denn die jahreszeiten sind in
maskulin der sommer
heißt es der die oder das nicht
[Musik]
frauen sind feminin also die nichte die
nichte
welchen artikeln braucht morgen
[Musik]
weil tageszeiten fast immer maskulin
sind ist es der morgen der morgen
und wie sieht es mit nordosten aus
[Musik]
himmelsrichtungen sind maskulin
also heißt es der nordosten genau der
nordosten
alle kennen das wort doch welchen
artikeln braucht gold
[Musik]
wie viele metalle ist gold neutral
das heißt dass gold
und wie ist es mit 6
[Musik]
die sechs denn zahlen sind feminin klar
die 6
wodka der die oder das
[Musik]
der wodka denn alkohol ist maskulin der
wodka
welchen artikeln braucht tornado
[Musik]
es heißt der tornado denn
wetterphänomene sind oft maskulin der
tornado
neue chance der die oder das großvater
[Musik]
er ist ein mann also der großvater der
großvater
lila der die oder das
[Musik]
farben sind neutral also das lila das
lila
welchen artikel hat dezember
[Musik]
wie alle monate ist der dezember
maskulin der dezember
die oder das bier
[Musik]
alkohol ist zwar maskulin aber das bier
ist eine ausnahme das bier
prost
sprechen wir über mich welchen artikeln
braucht moderator
[Musik]
ich bin der moderator
denn ich bin ein mann ja er ist der
moderator und ich bin die moderatorin
welchen artikel hat fernsehen
[Musik]
nominal ii sierte infiniti 'we sind
immer neutral
das fernsehen das fernsehen
heißt es der die oder das feiertag
[Musik]
nicht nur die wochentage sondern alle
wörter auf tag sind maskulin
also heißt es der feiertag
nun zu unserer letzten frage der die
oder das bmw
[Musik]
bmw produziert autos und motorräder also
der oder die autos der bmw motorrad die
bmw
sie sehen liebe zuschauer es ist gar
nicht so einfach
also lernen sie nun immer zusammen mit
dem artikel
sie sehen liebe zuschauer es ist gar
nicht so einfach
also lernen sie nun immer zusammen mit
dem artikel
und jetzt zurück zu professor genius
jetzt erkläre ich wie
an der änderung des namens erkennen kann
erkläre ich wie man den artikel an der
änderung des namens erkennen kann
deutsche namen mit der endung ling sind
immer maskulin
zum beispiel der schmetterlinge der
frühling
der häftling der säugling
deutschen mit der endung ling sind immer
maskulin zum beispiel der schmetterlinge
der frühling
der häftling der säugling
das gilt auch für nomen office muss
beispielsweise der
der journalismus oder der alkoholismus
das gilt auch für nomen office muss
beispielsweise der tourismus der
journalismus oder der alkoholismus
domain mit der endung verbrauchen
ebenfalls meistens den artikel der
wie sagen der motor der monitor der
alligator der humor aber das labor und
das tor
domain mit der endung brauchen ebenfalls
meistens den artikel der visagen der
motor der monitor der alligator der
humor aber das labor und das tor
fielen um auf ihr sind maskulin aber
nicht alle
der drucker der fehler der teller und
viele berufe wie der mechaniker wir
sagen aber beispielsweise das fenster
oder die leiter
fielen um auf ihr sind maskulin aber
nicht alle
der drucker der fehler der teller und
viele berufe wie der mechaniker wir
sagen aber beispielsweise das fenster
oder die leiter
die änderungen sind typisch für männer
deshalb sind diese wörter maskulin
zu gehören und end ist und leer
zu gehören und end ist und leer also der
demonstrant der patient der polizist
unter der sportler
also der demonstrant der patient der
polizist unter der sportler
wenn man en anhängt bekommt man eine
frau
die demonstrantinnen die patientin die
polizistin die sportlerin
man hängt bekommt man eine frau die
demonstrantinnen die patientin die
polizistin die sportlerin
nomen auf um sind feminin
zb die zeitung die begrüßung die
rechnung oder die verletzung
nomen auf um sind feminin so zum
beispiel die zeitung die begrüßung die
rechnung oder die verletzung
auch die änderungen haid und kalt
brauchen den artikeln die
auch die endungen heiß und kalt koch in
den artikeln die also die schönheit die
trockenheit die geschwindigkeit oder die
sauberkeit
also die schönheit die trockenheit die
geschwindigkeit oder die sauberkeit
ebenso sind würde auf normalerweise
feminin
so sind würde auf normalerweise feminin
das sind oft geschäfte wie die bäckerei
die metzgerei oder die bücherei
gleiche gilt für die endung schafft
die meisterschaft die freundschaft und
lustigerweise auch die mannschaft
das gleiche gilt für die endung schafft
die meisterschaft die freundschaft und
lustigerweise auch die mannschaft
eine häufige änderungen die den artikeln
die braucht ist ion
beispielsweise die operation die
religion die lektion oder die region
eine häufige änderungen die den artikeln
die braucht ist ihnen beispielsweise die
operation die religion die lektion oder
die region
und ans sind meistens feminin
auch nur fans und tanz sind meistens
feminin
dazu gehören die konferenz die abstinenz
die substanz und die ignoranz
meistens sind auch nehmen auf ie feminin
meistens sind auch nummern auf e feminin
wir sagen die phobie die industrie die
fotografie die energie
neutral sind hingegen die motive also
verkleinerungen auf line und tieren
den artikel das kochen zb das mädchen
das häuschen das tischlein das büchlein
neutral sind hingegen die motive also
verkleinerungen auf leyen und den
artikel das brauchen zb das mädchen das
häuschen das tischlein das büchlein zu
den neutralen änderungen zählt auch
mensch
das dokument das experiment oder das
medikament
die neutralen endungen zählt auch mit
also das instrument das dokument das
experiment oder das medikament nehmen
auf add sind ebenfalls neutral
das bett das schachbrett das skelett und
das ballett sind ein paar beispiele
blumenau fett sind ebenfalls neutral
das bett das schachbrett das skelett und
das ballett sind ein paar beispiele
auch nomen mit der endung um sind
meistens neutral
auch norman mit der endung um sind
so etwa das publikum das präsidium dass
die bi leon oder das studium
doch das war es mit der theorie zurück
zu meinen kollegen im quiz studio
vielen dank professor genius vielen dank
willkommen zurück bei der die oder das
artikel lernen macht spaß
unsere erste frage lautet welchen
artikel hat überraschung
[Musik]
wörter auf um sind feminin also die
überraschung die überraschung
liebling der die oder das
[Musik]
die endung ling macht wörter maskulin
also der liebling der liebling gilt
übrigens auch für frauen
welchen artikeln brauchen wir für museum
[Musik]
das museum
denn um ist typisch für neutralen um das
museum
unser nächstes wort ist kindheit welcher
artikel passt
[Musik]
wörter auf haid sind feminin also die
kindheit die kindheit
heißt es der die oder das gratulation
[Musik]
auch die endung wie ohnmacht wörter
feminin also die gratulation
die gratulation
welchen artikeln braucht roboter
[Musik]
meistens sind nomen auf eher maskulin
der roboter der roboter
[Musik]
und wie sieht es mit lieferanten aus
in ist die typische endung für feminine
berufe wie die lieferanten die
lieferantin
welchen artikeln braucht parlament
[Musik]
nomen auf mend sind neutral
also das parlament das parlament
ist es der die oder das hähnchen
[Musik]
in und line machen norman klein
wir sagen deshalb das hähnchen das
hähnchen
und welchen artikeln braucht autor
[Musik]
nomen auf sind normalerweise maskulin
egal ob person oder objekt das heißt
also der autor
intelligenz der die oder das
[Musik]
es ist eine typische feminine endung die
intelligent richtig die intelligenz ist
feminin
[Musik]
und wie ist es mit polizei
nomen mit der endung de sind feminin
also die polizei die polizei
ein langes wort welchen artikeln braucht
filmproduzent
[Musik]
die endung and bezeichnet männer also
der filmproduzent der filmproduzent
ist es der die oder das kotelett
[Musik]
die endung at braucht den neutralen
artikel das kotelett das kotelett
welcher artikel gehört zu landschaft
[Musik]
es ist die landschaft weil schafft
wörter feminin macht die landschaft
wer kennt den artikel von optimismus
[Musik]
es muss ist eine typische maskuline
endung also der optimismus der
optimismus
und unsere letzte frage heißt es der die
oder das demokratie
[Musik]
die endung braucht oft den artikeln die
also die demokratie
die demokratie
wir sind schon am ende unserer quizshow
der die oder das artikel lernen macht
spaß
wie viele artikel haben sie richtig
gewählt schreiben sie es in die
kommentare
und nicht vergessen lernen sie nun immer
zusammen mit dem artikel
richtig lernen sie die nun immer
[Musik]
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video